I did everything that voice told me to
do that night had that voice have told
me to jump off Thames Bridge I would
have done it please welcome David
it's U.S drama home
the most influential voices on race and
mental health
I remember reading about a moment when
you come home you find your father's
typewriter with one word written on the
typewriter which is an illness and I
didn't quite know what it was but I knew
something was off I haven't seen dad for
a while and then one morning I got up
and my mom said don't go into the
kitchen and go straight to school out
the front door for that night that's
when my mom told me that that'd be
David Harewood was the first black actor
to play this part the hostility that I
was met with as a young black actor was
ferocious newspapers reviews just
dismissing me he looks more like Mike
Tyson than Romeo what's he doing on the
stage so I really did feel like I was an
anomaly the whole thing the stress the
smoke the overthinking just ended up
making me spiral that's what led to me
just falling into psychosis I was lying
in bed and I just heard this voice in my
head he said he was Martin Luther King
even though I'm speaking to you from
Beyond the Grave I need you to close the
gap between good and evil so you're
gonna sacrifice yourself tonight and
you're going to be an angel and that was
the night I was eventually sectioned I
just remember lots of flashing lights
and then being in the back of a police
wagon if that would have continued I'm
not even sure I would have been here
today
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the Diary of a CEO if I can have any
favors from you if you've ever watched
the show and enjoyed it it's just to
please hit the Subscribe button without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what do I have to understand about your
very earliest years to understand
the man you are this perspective you
have and the work you do today what is
the most important context
wow that's an interesting question what
do I need to what do you need to know
about me then
um that I was probably naive
open innocent uh and
probably more
um
probably more conflicted than I thought
I was
I I was a vessel and into that vessel
was just been poured so much
I'll say false information wrong
information
that um
at some point it had to
smash
break
I grew up at a time when there weren't
many black people on television and
there weren't many
black images
that on television or anywhere
and I think
I think that is I think that seriously
put me at a disadvantage but I I grew up
with a false sense of myself and that
that
false
false picture
uh has only recently emerged does that
make sense
not entirely unless I get further
context what was the picture of yourself
you grew up with
I would say you know
I just think I was just way too naive
and way too
way too
that's hard that's a really interesting
question I had really thought about that
but I think
it's only it's only in recently recent
years and having asked myself
some of the questions that I've been
asking myself over these last couple of
years and I've really started to get a
real grip of
the person that I am
so who did you think you are when you
when you were younger what did you think
of the world in yourself when you're
younger that was so naive and
ill-informed
um
I think I was
I didn't really think it was important
I don't think my color was important
and that's why I say I was naive I
didn't think my color was that important
I had no concept of myself
as a sort of
young black man
and that's why I say I grew up at a time
and there weren't any images of myself
so I couldn't really
structure my identity
[Music]
around a sort of solid identity and even
my you know my mother was always sort of
trying to steer me into a more
Afrocentric mindset
now I got back to Birmingham where I
where I'm from and I look at how many of
us are in interracial relationships of
that generation we were constantly told
to assimilate it was all about
assimilating assimilate you're not even
my you know I I heard the one I heard
the phrase one time you're not black
you're normal
which is so bizarre
so that your identity as a black person
was sort of ironed out you you just you
just
you're British you're English and
and
so when I came out of drama school I
think and the world said to me
you're black
it was a real sort of wake-up call for
me
and
seriously contributed to
what happened two years after I left
going back to your your mother and your
father how was their relationship and
your early experience with them shaped
the man that you are today
who are they as people
wonderful people in a very very
um my mother was extremely strong
and uh
my dad was a kind of a quiet silent type
really
uh very proud
um
didn't really speak much
didn't really
um
it wasn't wasn't particularly involved
in our education wasn't particularly
involved in shaping
who we were you know he
was very much hands off
you know it was a long distance large
driver so he was away a lot
and when he came back he would sort of
sit and what's the telly
and in peace and just you know
I often tried to talk to him when I was
a kid but he he was a very difficult man
to sort of
open up
um whereas my mother was my mother was
always sort of talking and
and sort of cajoling and very welcoming
of her friends and
she was just a really wonderful
character and still is very very funny
but you know she tells me now stories
that she used to you know some of the
fights that she had some of the battles
that she had
when I was writing my book
you know as I said we were the only
black family on that street and
she was constantly in conflict with
with
neighbors with
um racists
and she didn't back down she was very
very sharp and fearless
sounds like my mother Fearless
your father
um you write a lot about how hard
working he was
um the the lack of affection you've
described there the lack of openness
um
as you look back now was there a is
there was that was there a cost to that
to him and to
the family to you
I think so I think so I think I think
the fact that he didn't that's difficult
because it feels as like I'm criticizing
him
and I don't really want to do that but
I think it was a loving home
there was a lot of laughter in the house
but that's you know he he loved
you know all the British sitcoms and of
the time and
one of my favorite sounds was the sound
of him laughing I loved
hearing him laugh hear my mum laughed it
was the house seemed full of laughter
when I was growing up so there was a lot
of
you know there was a lot of humor in the
house but there wasn't necessarily a lot
of tenderness
and you know I I kissed my kids every
morning when they go to school it's just
that why but I
I don't know why that's important to me
maybe it's just become habit but I want
them to know how much I love them and I
want them to know
um how much respect I have for them and
how much how proud I am it's important
for me to do that and maybe it's because
my dad didn't do that
not not because
not because he he um
purposely didn't do it I just think just
don't think he thought it was that
important maybe
do you think he knew how to do that I
don't know if he did
I don't know if he did and um
but I think that's kind of true of a lot
of men of that generation
showing emotion wasn't very easy for
them
and also I think
it's really interesting a friend of mine
tells me this story of
it's very particular to the 60s and 70s
which is why I'm you know I was a
director and and
I'm very I'm fascinated by this period
of
late 50s 60s 70s England
because I don't think people understand
the level of racism
that was present in this country and
he's got goosebumps then because they
don't understand it and the idea of
being othered
that you would leave your house and
literally take your life into your hands
I mean I remember
randomly getting off a bus
and instantly being chased by a group of
skinheads and you would just
automatically find yourself runny
now
to to be to to have come here
from the Caribbean with ideas of streets
are paved with gold England being the
mother country
to have come here with that idea and to
be met with that amount of hostility
to be met with
with
that amount of abuse that amount of
rejection
I think it's seriously damaged
not just my father but many people who
came here in that generation that
Windows generation because it's
fascinating to me how many
Caribbean parents
do not want to talk about that period
just do not want to go there
because I think it was horrific
and I think it damaged him
I haven't really thought about that
before well I you know really considered
it before but I do think
that was a tough period for a lot of a
lot of us and whereas in America you
know movies have been made plays have
been written about that
generation about that um period we've
not really looked at it
I have to be completely honest I you
know I grew up in 90 I was born in 1992
came to the UK when I was two years old
from Botswana
um
I I always saw my mum have this I'll
describe it as this like
competitive uh
I'd say it's slightly competitive
attitude towards people and this like
General belief that other people were
racist and I never understood it I never
understood I never fully understood it I
just thought she she viewed the world as
big being racist and as I've done this
podcast and specifically spoken to
people from
the 50s 60s 70s 80s
and and early 90s
my mind has been blown because I don't
get I didn't get it of course you know
and it's interesting as I listened to
the wonderful Chris yeah and the world
that he was talking about I know that
I've I I remember it
you know growing up in those in in I was
born just after Chris
and five years after Chris but those
which is why he's such a legend for me
why him still Regis they are legends
because as kids I watch them playing
football knowing full well
that 50 of that the crowd were giving
him so much abuse
regularly
and yet he was able to play football
smile score goals play aggressively I
was in all of those guys because I just
thought
I would be scared
as a kid I was scared and that's one of
the things I've touched upon in my book
is is owning up to that idea that
I was terrified growing up in those days
because you just never knew
where a brick would come from where
where you know your a car would a car
would suddenly you'd be walking down the
street whistling yourself having a great
day next thing you know [ __ ]
[Music]
just monkey noises would just come from
nowhere
and
you would just tighten tense up so I
grew up in that environment and that's
why I'm I'm well aware of it which is
probably it goes back to that your first
question about
what you need to know about me
that's the environment I grew up in so I
it was trying to form a sense of myself
it's constantly being
sort of
it's growing up at a period where you're
othered
where you're in fear
and not understanding
Who You Are
was destabilizing I think and I'm in a
sense lucky that my house fell down when
it did and I was able to
put it back together again
where a brick would come from
you talk about a story being I think
five years old where brick comes through
the window of your family home
well
[Music]
I wrote about it in the book and how how
you know exactly mornings was always
cartoon morning you know Saturday
morning cartoons back in the day again
you're too young tonight
um but it was always you know Tom and
Jerry and
Pepe Le Pew and I love Tom and Jerry it
was great it was just they were just on
constantly so you would sort of
you know you'd sort of run down and and
watch Telly and and my my mum's my mum
was famous for her breakfasts
English breakfast
bacon eggs just chips Paula English
which we used to love and I remember my
mum calling us down
for breakfast and running down the
stairs and then hearing this smash
and we ran into the lounge
and there was an English breakfast
in glass
because a brick had come through the
window
and just
there was glass all over our big kitchen
table
and we just all sort of stood there in
shock
and Mom said go back to bed
drapes back up the road back up to back
up to bed
but that was a sort of you don't know
where it came from
in the where it came from but we were
targets
your mum's reaction
there when I read about this seemed
uncomfortably calm
well what are you gonna do you know and
she wasn't always calm and there was
times when she
she did you know grab people by the
colors and have people up there have
people up the wall she's fearless and uh
you know don't you ever call my son
that's like get that name again and she
was you know she was
Fearless but at the same time
you're powerless in that
in that
setting
because you don't know who threw that
brick
and
um you're almost you know I think back
to it now and think
you know she she used to sort of walk me
to school
and be waiting at the school gate to
walk me home
and for me that was it was great to see
my mom's face at the end of school
um
but I realized later maybe why she did
that because when you did go home on
your own years later it was a bit of a
minefield
you had to be careful
you were a target people don't
understand that especially people
especially people that haven't
experienced race racist debut the idea
of leaving the school Gates and the the
journey home being anxious
and looking over your shoulder anxious
there's a good word that's a good word
yeah which I you know we I didn't
realize at the time but I think it was a
huge amount of anxiety and then the
thing that the amazing thing about it is
you might go a week without it you might
go two weeks without it you might go
three weeks with it and then you and you
relax yeah sure and then you're normal
and then Bang casual Wednesday afternoon
middle of the day [ __ ]
and suddenly you're right back to being
scared
and uh
I I don't really think
my you know I I I I I think my whole
sense of self
because you know you do your best to
sort of
you do your best to normalize
that stuff and think I'm not gonna let
it affect me and I always had this and
then my mother's
words ringing my head don't let it
affect you hold your head up be strong
so you keep thinking no no I'm gonna
I'm not gonna let this affect me is that
good advice
well you know I think yes
yes but um
it doesn't always work
it doesn't always work and the the the
you know it crystallized for me when
rather foolishly
I went I was a leader I don't know why I
was a lead United fan
and and
um
always used to watch watching Leeds
United they were the champions back then
and they came to Birmingham one year to
to to to play Birmingham city and like a
jackass
I thought I'm gonna go and sit in the
Leeds end
and back in the day back in the day you
could um at half time you could
literally walk into the ground
so I thought you know
I think I was about 12 maybe about 9 10
or something like that
and I at half time I thought I'm gonna
sit with the lease fans
the idea of it now but I walked into the
leads and at first it was just a couple
of monkey noises
and then it became like a chorus of
monkey noises
and then he became a chorus of go [ __ ]
and then it seemed like
thousands of people
was screaming abuse at me and I heard
these words in my my mother's words hold
your head up don't be scared
so I thought I'm gonna go and take my
seat
and I kept walking down the touchline
but it got so loud
that in the end I thought I don't want
to sit with these people
so I turned around and walked away and
they cheat I remember them cheering
but I remember I was really shaken
and I remember that I remember to this
day this groundsman
well Ward you know to start member of
Staff as I walked out the ground he shot
you're like you're right kid
and I just went I was nodded and just
walked home
but I was really shaken by it
because I'd done exactly what my mother
told me to
but it didn't work
in in your early teens after that your
father's mental health began to
deteriorate
what were the were there any events that
led up to that I I remember reading
about a moment where you come home the
lights are on and there's you find your
father's typewriter with one word
written on the typewriter yeah you just
said illness
uh my dad was a prolific
sort of organizer
and uh
he started this this Darts League and
I was always on the typewriter writing
out the results and writing out that
who's played who and who had won and who
was going through to the next round and
who needed the trophy and who was gonna
where they were gonna play and what
times they played and he just he loved
the darts
but he just took too much on
and
um
he was constantly sort of working at
this organizing this whole thing and
organizing the trophies at the end of
the season organizing the meeting
organizing that he was just always I
think he was just doing it all on his
own
and um
I I just think he just took
on too much
and um
I didn't I didn't necessarily I didn't
necessarily
see it coming because I was quite Young
but um
it happened very very quickly
and
I always used to hear my dad go to work
in the mornings which is he was Keys
jingle jangle down the stairs
that was sort of my
alarm
to get up for school was my dad hearing
my dad come downstairs and think all
right I've got to get up in a minute
and for a couple of days I didn't hear
it
and then we kept hearing arguments in my
in the in my mum and Dad's bedroom
and I thought this is something's not
right
I'm saying that for a while
I've heard the jingle jangle down the
stairs something's off I didn't quite
know what it was but I knew something
was off and then one morning I got up
and my mom said
don't go into the kitchen
get changes up in the bedroom and go
straight to school at the front door
and um I did
and then that night
that's when my mom told me that that had
been sectioned so it happened it
happened really
quickly and they sort of kept me away
from it but unbeknownst to me my
brothers were
holding my dad down in the kitchen
because he would he he sort of lost it
how do they explain being sectioned to
you when you're in your early teens
because I you know I
I would have no idea what that meant in
my early teens
they didn't really and it's
it was you know Dad's not well
father's not well he's been taken to
hospital
and
you know there's always that gig when
there was that all there's always that
sort of
that uh Gadget school that you know the
men in the white coats will take you
away you know you'll create that's you
know you're crazy or are you gonna be
you're going to be taken away
and
that's what happened
my dad was taken away
um I didn't see it but I I knew he was
I knew that he'd been
unknown now obviously I'm having my
recent years I know that that's what had
happened to him he'd been sectioned
and when I was sectioned
um
I I suddenly realized
that
I suddenly read especially when I was
writing the book I thought that's what
has happened to him and and that now
it's only once I'd written my book and
really understood what that was like
having your Liberty taken away from you
because I think that in prison is about
the only being locked up in prison about
the only times when your Liberty is
taken away from you
and
it was only then I started asking myself
sort of started looking at my Dad's life
in sort of retrospect and thinking
because he hated it my dad hated it
and was never the same again when he
when he was released he was never the
same again and
I don't
think
I think he had a really bad time in
there
a really really difficult
and bad time which I don't think he ever
forgave my mother for
understanding what you understand now
about the nature of mental health and
what causes it and your own experiences
with mental health
when you look at why how your father
became to be sectioned
have you got any suspicions about why
that happened beyond that he took on too
much at the darts
I do think that there was a lot of
resentment and anger built up in him
and you've got to wonder
why and this is I only found this out
again once I started writing my book and
started looking at Mental Health
and the numbers of black black people
are over represented in the mental
health system in this country
and what I realized is that
it was Jamaican
psychologist who
who actually performed this um study and
he realized that black people
there's way less Mental Health
in Africa amongst black black
communities there is mental health
problems but way less psychosis and
but there's more in when they are
transmitted to a western culture so
there's more Mental Health
episodes of mental health in England
amongst the black community and in
America amongst the black community and
I think there's something about
I call it in my and this is one of the
things that my therapist talks about
when you're in a white space
and that's not a derogatory term but
England is essentially a
what space
and I'm sure you've been
in rooms where you're the only person
color
the higher ladder when they call it tall
poppy syndrome where the higher up the
ladder you get the less yeah on your own
people you see and
I think you know my thing I think
I think my dad had found it very
difficult coming from
the Caribbean
and coming to England
and
dealing with a completely different
mindset
I think he'd found that
difficult
and
um
resentment had built up
and I I think I was going to say a point
earlier on that illustrates this but a
friend of mine used to told me that
his dad used to work on an assembly line
and in the days of in the 70s when Jim
Davidson was
doing his chalky routine
that and he was the only black person on
the assembly line every Monday morning
after new faces or whatever it was that
Jim was on the comedians or everything
was doing his chalky thing every Monday
morning he would be chalky
and his dad would laugh and take it and
and then you know throughout the week
they'd be calling him chalky any big
daily development name chalky chalky
he's chalky his dad would laugh
and then on Friday night his dad would
get drunk and beat the [ __ ] out of him
and his mother
and I think that was just a buildup of
resentment
of having to live in this place where
yeah everyone's calling me this name
everyone thinks it's funny
and I'm laughing but there's a buildup
of resentment that he then takes out on
his family
now I'm not saying my I'm not saying my
dad
had that level of resentment but I think
it was just something about being here
that
he started to find difficult to live
with cope with mentally
when I read through
your book and also a lot of the stories
you've told me today I mean I remember
one particular story where you gotta you
got a girlfriend in school and then you
come into school the next day her father
has said that she can't be with you
because you're black this constant
constant rejection social rejection you
used that word earlier on the word
rejection and it feels so apt because
that's really what's I think in a
psychological psychological level going
on even going to the football and then
being rejected socially from that crowd
and it's constant throughout your story
you know I've read these studies about
labeling Theory where when the world
tells when you tell somebody they are
something in these studies they they
eventually become it so you know there's
the famous prison study where they said
you're the guards who are the prisoners
they had to stop the study because the
guards were so harsh on the prisoners
and labeling 3 says exactly that your
teacher says you're a d and you're going
to be a failure the chances are that'll
actually lower your performance your
self-belief how do you stop that
happening when Society has rejected you
for years and years and years growing up
the most formative time
I think you know I think I was lucky
because I I do think that uh
I lived amongst a lot of people who uh
you know who didn't Define you that way
so I think that was I was very very
lucky for that
but
I
think
I think that person had to I think that
house had to come down
which is why I think my breakdown was
all about the more I learned about it
the more I
realize that that image of that young
boy
a desire to start again I had to rebuild
my image of self
and
um
that's what I've sort of it's
interesting because I even though it
happened 30 years ago I'm only now just
dealing with it because I only found the
records I only did that documentary I
only all this is recent and I think if
I'd talk to you last year
I'd probably be in tears by now because
so much of this is recent for me I'm
having to deal with a lot of it I just
I've spent the last 30 years in this
sort of cocoon not really
dealing with a lot of this stuff
and it's only since reading my medical
records and doing that documentary and
uncovering all that trauma as I say the
first thing I read when I opened my
medical records from 30 years ago
which were the medical records that the
BBC found in the bowels of the
Whittington psychiatric hospital
I had no idea they were going to give
them to me no idea I had no idea they
even found them the first thing I read
was patient believes
he has merged hearts with a young black
boy
and I just thought what is that
what is and I just looked through the
medical records and it's all to do with
my race and my identity
all of it I was just confused
I'd sort of Lost
touch with my
identity going off to drama school and
playing Romeo and Pushkin and doing all
these doing Molly air and Dostoevsky
doing all these European romantic you
know playwrights and Shakespeare and all
these different characters and thinking
my character my color doesn't matter I
can do all these wonderful things and
then I came out of drama school and
every newspaper article
was all about my color
every job I went through was all about
my color
I could go for these jobs and not these
jobs
and I it just
it was like it it was like I hadn't
was like I hadn't um
dealt with it
and dealt with my core identity
as a young black man
and
it all started to just
I started overthink it
what was your core identity that you
hadn't dealt with as a black man
I think just understanding myself as you
what your first question was
understanding myself in the world and
knowing
having confidence in myself there's too
many questions about my identity I think
one of the things I
did when I
saw a therapist after my documentary
was I sought out
I've had therapy many times in my life
but I sought out a black therapist
a black male therapist
and that has been really strikingly
revealing
to me
because some of the questions I had he
would kind of say well what do you think
why do you think like that and he would
question why I think like that
and
I found it remarkable how
he was able to make me understand that a
lot of things that I most a lot of my
fears a lot of my insecurities
only natural
uh
maybe potentially because I have maybe
grown up
predominantly in the white environment
and maybe I didn't
maybe I wasn't comfortable with myself
I'm much more comfortable with myself
now
what were those fears and insecurities
foreign
black man
you know
great at dancing great at sex great
chatting women upgraded it's great at
that
and
I felt maybe that I didn't always live
up to that
and if you have that
idea that
you can only be one way as a black man
but the world is telling you that you
could only be this way
then you sort of don't feel like you
measure up
and
actually I've learned yeah you can be
vulnerable
that's okay
you can be sensitive that's okay you
um it's okay to be
not be
you know
darkest McFly you know who just beats
down all the girls dances fantastically
does you know he's the Alpha Black
it's okay not to be the alpha black guy
it's okay
and uh that's taken me
a while to sort of understand about
myself
I think Jay-Z it's interesting I think
there's a thing about Jay-Z talks about
the gold silver bronze
the gold I think it's a book called How
to be black it's a very very funny book
we talked about the gold silver bronze
um black man you know the gold born in
the ghetto black wife black friends you
know
silver ball in the ghetto
black wife went to University bronze
you know and you sort of you sort of get
less and less you're almost like you get
less it must be copper or something yeah
and and then you see but then you see
the effects of that in schools where you
go where you have teachers will tell me
that you know you get a really
intelligent black kid but just to fit in
with his peer groups he won't work as
hard because he fears the more
intelligent he is the less black he is
the brighter he is the less black he's
seen the more and I hate that isn't that
funny being rejected by the White
Community but also the black community
well that's exactly what I had so you
know when I came out of Radha so I had I
had tough I had this sort of when I was
started being an actor you know
blackmens I'm like you're gonna be a
what
that's too white
you're too white man and then I went to
Radha and kind of did all these
Shakespeare all these plays and I came
out speaking like this and everybody
went he's way too white
and so you're getting rejected by the
press and critics because you're black
and then you were also being rejected by
the black community because they you
don't look or see them sound like
you know man from the ends you don't
sound like you don't talk like that
so I really did feel like I was
an anomaly a quick word from one of our
sponsors I've got a tip for all of you
that will make your virtual meeting
experiences I think 10 times better as
some of you may know by now Blue Jeans
by Verizon offers seamless high quality
video conferencing but the reason why I
use blue jeans versus other video
conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events
my girlfriend came upstairs yesterday
when I was having a shower and she said
to me that she tried the heel protein
shake which lives on my fridge over
there and she said it's amazing low
calories you get your 20 odd grams of
protein you get your 26 vitamins and
minerals and it's nutritionally complete
then the protein space there's lots of
things but it's hard to find something
that is nice especially when consumed
just with water and that is
nutritionally complete and that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein if
you haven't tried the heel protein
product do give it a try The Salted
Caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because I'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and I'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where he all fits in my life thank you
heal for making a product that I
actually like The Salted Caramel is my
favorite I've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is the one
at age 23 I think it's age 23 you
um that's that's around the time you
were sectioned yeah this is a very
strange way of asking the question but
in hindsight knowing now what you know
about why you were sectioned what was
going on in your life your mind your
environment the Press professionally
personally
what would you have had to change a void
do differently
before then
to have avoided that happening
that's a million dollar question
this really is a million dollar question
and I'm not sure there was any
anything I could have done
I think that
I think it had to come down
so I I'm I'm a great believer that
in trauma there's a lesson
that
there was something in that for me of
value
I don't think any I don't think
I mean I was very lucky that I came out
of it but I do believe and as I have got
older in my life
and having written the book and having
had so many people
tell me since writing that book
has so many people say thank you
I'm not crazy thank you he really you
really articulated everything that goes
on in my some of the frustrations that
comments I've only given voice to a
thing to things that a lot of people
experience just I took it to an extreme
I think
and I think it's
probably uh
as an artist as an actor has benefited
some of my work
it's enabled me to take things perhaps a
step further than maybe what some people
can take things I think it's given me a
perspective
I think there's something I think there
was something of value for oh in it for
me
I don't
I think it had to happen I don't think I
could have done anything to have stopped
it
which is
both um scary and um
worrying
what do you remember about that time
because it seems to be quite a blur when
you recount the events you it's almost
like you have these abstract memories of
just different moments well it's
interesting because I do believe I I
started this process thinking
that it was going to be fun
because it's like manic you know manic
depression it is often psychosis
like like it's often preceded with a
Mania
heightened
Adrenaline Rush dopamine the dopamine
levels in your brain are heightened and
it's quite exciting
I'm not getting sleep
it's often drug induced and you are
really sort of
operating at this quite high level
and I
I remember doing some pretty
extraordinary things I remember brief
moments of real sort of
mental acuity and
dare I say there was almost moments of
fun
but it's usually preceded by a crash
so I sort of went into this thinking I'm
gonna I'm gonna remember all our fun
things I did
some of the extraordinary things I did
and there were some really
Wild
things I was experimenting with
a sense of reality what was real and
what wasn't real
thinking I could do anything and
it was uh
bizarrely
exciting
give me an example of something that you
recount that is well it's interesting
because my
one of the Consultants that was in the
documentary
tells me that um
because I thought she asked me for an
example and I
I said I was walking walking down the
street one one morning
I hadn't slept all night
and uh
there was a guy across the road and he
had this huge Doberman
huge kind of massive muscular and I'm
normally quite afraid of dogs
and I just walked up to this I walked up
to this guy said what's that dog's name
and he
jab or something and I looked at this
dog and I screamed the dog's name and
looks at this dog quite aggressively and
right in its face and the dog just
literally
literally lay on the floor and started
whelping
whelping on its back just freaked out
and the consultant said to me that often
dogs can pick up
um
some some
uh Energies
Disturbed images
and I'd obviously really this guy was
really freaked out he said the dog was
literally whelping and moaning on the
floor and I just fixed this dog with no
fear and screened its name right in its
face just freaked the dog out
at night you were sectioned I read I
read that you were you hailed a taxi and
it was ultimately the exchange of the
taxi driver I mean this was an
extraordinary I mean that was an
extraordinary and again
it was the voice of Martin Luther King
that was in my head
you hear voices and when you uh
one of the aspects of
psychosis which is what I suffered from
you can hear voices he'd have Illusions
illusions
delusions
that seem incredibly real to you
and um
I was lying in bed
and I just heard this voice in my head
wake up
in bed looking around the room thinking
where's that come from
and this voice was in my head
it sounds totally bizarre but
his voice was in my head
and he went on to say look I don't want
to tell you who I am right now because
you're going to be really scared
but you have to go to Camden
you have to walk into this store don't
be surprised if it's open it's three
o'clock in the morning don't be
surprised to open whatever you do do not
turn around and it was all these things
I had to do
whatever you do don't do this whatever
you do don't do that but then go to go
into this store walk to the back of the
store there's going to be one suit
hanging up on a rack in the back at the
back of the store you need to put this
suit on and when you turn around don't
be surprised to find out that it's two
o'clock in the afternoon I said I'm
gonna I'm going to close the space time
continuum and we are going to close the
gap between good and evil this whole
thing
and it was it ended up being Martin
Luther King he said he was Martin Luther
King
and he said when you when you
because I played mine as a king as a kid
and it was my first
the first acting thing that I'd ever
done
he said when you played me as a child I
entered your heart
and when I was he said even though I'm
speaking to you from Beyond the Grave
I need you and two or three other people
in in the world to
activate something
and close the the the gap between good
and evil and he said so you're going to
sacrifice yourself tonight and you're
going to be an angel
and this voice was
swear to you
was like
real in my head
and I'm sobbing in my bedroom listening
to this voice so tonight's the night and
that was the night I was eventually
sectioned but I got up
got my clothes on and walked all the way
to Camden
obviously the shop was closed
it's 10 o'clock in the morning you know
I'm out of my nuts so um
and I was exhausted and I thought I've
got to go home and flagged a cab down
and I didn't have any money
and uh I don't remember I just I just
remember this driver looking around and
then the driver pulling over and then
um lots of flashing lights obviously the
police
and then being in the back of a police
wagon
and then
sitting in a cell and all this was just
I'm in and out of
what seemed like a dream for me I didn't
I I was in and out of I remember being
in this cell and then going to
magistrates court in the morning
and not remembering when they didn't
remember my name
at all didn't know who I was
couldn't remember who I was
and um
the duty solicitor sort of talking about
my mom and then said my dad's name is
Romeo and I went Romeo
hang on a minute I've played Romeo
yeah I played Romeo played running you
David David
that's I used my I used my sort of
career to get back to who I was
then left went to court
and I had no idea what was happening in
this court I mean I was the judge was
speaking at me and I was just
a mess
and I walked out of court and again
lucky but some woman who'd been in the
court
walked out and said
to me are you okay and I said I don't
think so
I don't know I don't know who I am and
she gets she said where do you live and
I said I can't remember she said what's
your nearest Tube Station
and I said yeah hybridizlington and she
flagged the cab down gave the driver 10
pounds said take him to hybrid Islington
and I got out of Hope in Islington
walked home and my friends were
waiting for me because I've been looking
for me all night couldn't find me
and that's the night that's the day that
they
knew something was even though they'd
been sitting with me
and visiting me for the last couple of
weeks because they knew something was
off
they knew it wasn't well
and that's the weird thing about
mental health or particularly psychosis
you see somebody
acting very strangely something you love
it could be your son your husband your
mom your they just suddenly start acting
out of character
becoming obsessed with something or
it's like they just suddenly change and
you know you know something's wrong
but you sort of Hope desperately hoping
that they sort of come back
and that's sometimes you know they don't
and you have to make that call
to have them sectioned and luckily for
me
my friends had been there because if
they weren't there I think I would have
been in real trouble
oh my God I would have been in real
trouble
if that would have continued
I'm not even sure I would have been
here today
so I was very lucky
how long did that process last before
you were sectioned of the slope the sort
of gradual deterioration well I think it
was happening for a while because I I
remember working
and not feeling great
so I'd say at least two or three months
there was a slow progression
of
not sleeping
overthinking
trying to hide that
drinking
to sort of
self-medicate a new one wasn't well
but I thought I could handle it
I'm trying to understand how much of
that you believe is to a physiological
biological
situation or maybe predisposed by
biology versus circumstance experience
and
the things that you'd been through
I think and again I mean we didn't you
know speaking to my con the consultant
who
was working on my documentary It's a
combination of both things
your propensity your your
uh the chances of you having a breakdown
are sort of reliant on levels of stress
lack of sleep
what's called Aces which are these
fundamental like people who
experience trauma
in life I mean for me I think it was
my parents divorce
and not dealing with that
not dealing with that at the time so
much of it has just been squashed not
dealing with some of the trauma that was
in my life and I think a lot of it was
coming out
slowly coming out then in that one slow
progression of being deeply unhappy
why
why were you deeply unhappy I read that
and I thought what I as I say I came out
of drama school
and the hostility
that I was met with as a young black
actor
was ferocious newspapers newspapers
reviews just dismissing me completely
dismissing me and I sort of left John's
school with a bit of heat people are all
really excited to see what I was going
to do and
school was very very excited to you know
everybody was talking about this young
young kid coming out of drama school
it's going to be you know and I just got
slaughtered
slaughtered all about race all about
race
I played Sloan
in Entertaining Mr Sloan Mrs lonia who
is quite a devious bisexual character
murder he's actually also a murderer and
um
not only there was one review a black
reviewer who said who was outraged that
I'd taken the part because I was letting
the side down
and he said that people should go and
demonstrate their disapproval
of Mr harewood's choice of employment
and
I read it I was like wow
put that down and I noticed that night
people as Sloane has this really kind of
tough monologue
we talked about abusing somebody and
in the middle of this monologue I saw
people get up and walk out
and I noticed that they were black
and then the next night more black
people started walking out and it was
always in the middle of that monologue
black people would get up
and walk out
and it was really tough to deal with
it was really tough to try and they were
such
Chop Sing and
but as they walked out
and sort of it was really disturbing me
because I had to
get on with the play
and that was only the second act there
was another three so the whole way
through that play I Was sort of coping
with why did they walk out
get on with the play seems to be quite
an apt metaphor for that period of your
life
yeah and I wasn't really dealing with it
so dealing with the fundamentals so I
think
that's when the drinking started
to to be able to get through the play I
started drinking to be able to I started
self-medicating so I was drinking a lot
before during after the show smoking
after the show
and the whole thing the stress the smoke
the overthinking
lack of sleep lack of sleep
just ended up
making me spiral
how long from being section to getting
back to acting how long was that sort of
recovery process per se it was a lot
quicker than I realized actually which I
which surprised me I thought it was
going to be months but it was I was
sectioned for about five days initially
and then again in Birmingham
for another
five days
um
and then the recovery was just about
convincing my mother that I was okay
because she was she was convinced that
it was acting it was acting that sent me
crazy and then I was never going to act
again
and that I was never going to go back to
London again I was never going to be
allowed to act again
uh
so she kind of watched me like a hawk
for about a month
maybe a month six weeks
and eventually
uh she she allowed me to travel back
down to London and get on with my career
I sat here with uh Maisie Williams
um the young Game of Thrones actress and
she talked to me about how act acting
was a form of escapism in her life
because her home had such little joy
that acting became this place almost
this therapeutic place where she could I
guess in some respects abandon that
identity and I remember reading from
this like Swedish philosopher which I
wrote about my book Once Upon a Time who
said that when we um if we try and
abandon ourselves
um well ultimately just bear around he
wrote this 200 years ago so he was just
you know yeah if it's still true that's
right yeah that's why I really it always
stayed with me if we try and abandon
ourselves and we're successful we'll
despair at the fact that we've abandoned
ourselves and our identity if we try and
abandon ourselves and we're unsuccessful
we'll despair at being unsuccessful in
our in our attempts to become other than
we are and he concludes in his like big
philosopher piece that the only true way
to be happy is to accept that which you
who you are and to not abandon yourself
um he you know that's his conclusion
after this long study that he's done on
people
um it that kind of felt almost quite
true when I think about what acting is
in many respects but for Maisie it was
this this attempt to abandon the self
and actually to not confront the issues
and then she ultimately had to at some
point
confront those issues and what had gone
on in her family home what her father
had done to her but acting was her
Escape at 12 or 13.
is any of that reminiscent to or does
any of that ring true specifically this
idea of like the role acting played in
identity for you
acting is the only space I feel 100
confident in why
because everyone knows the lines
everyone knows where they're going to go
everyone knows the movement everyone
knows the play on stage I just feel it's
probably my what's where I'm at my
happiest
why
it's I can't explain it I just become
you become somebody else you know when
you're when you're
the true nature of a thing of art it's
like somebody who paints I think you
know they want to create something and
they're free to create like Van Gogh
could be taught that it could be
tortured but he can still produce an
amazing piece of art you said that I'm
not disappointing because I become
someone else so what does that say about
oneself if I'm myself I'm full of this
insecurities there's doubts there's
there's decisions to make there's about
which is what which is why life I think
is so
unique
I don't know what you're going to say
next none of us know that's what's so
beautiful about it and so fantastic
about it but on stage it's a controlled
environment so for those two hours
can be king Lear I can be a fellow and I
completely put myself into that and it's
that's I feel it's like I'm at I guess
you would I guess you could say I'm
football to say that
you know on the pitch
no problems George best on the pitch a
genius off it
an alcoholic
somebody who can't con somebody who
can't cope Maradona on the pitch a
genius off the pitch something else you
can't cope with
life life is
uncontrollable life is
full of contradictions full of
difference full of
failures and success it's just it's it's
uh
it's very difficult to distill
whereas on stage
I know you know I can play that
and I
can put myself into that and pour myself
into that character and I feel great
it's the most freeing place for me it's
the most
freeing thing I could it can I've ever
experienced and that's why I love it so
much that's What Maisie said
she said it was for her she said
actually it was the only place she
experienced Joy yeah I could not
completely completely understand that
but what that not to be repetitive but
what is that saying about the nature of
our our life in terms of why can't life
be joyous as equally joyous what would
we have to do to make our our acting
life when we're King well that's the
secret I guess and that's that's the
secret of sort of finding a place where
you can be and I'm sort of on the way
you know where you can experience joy
and I think that's that's a
it's a lifelong struggle but you have to
work at it 2019 you was the the first
time 2017-2019 was the first time she
really opened up about your experiences
in terms of to the Press I'd always I I
mean like that's that was the
shock of it is that I tweeted
2017 tweet randomly tweeted
as somebody who's had a breakdown just
want to say look have a great that was
meant World mental health day oh yeah
somebody's had a breakdown I just want
to say look after yourself today get
some help if you can
got on the plane flew to America got off
the plane 50 000 retweets
calls from ITV calls from the BBC course
from the guardian calls from the
Independent oh my God you had to break a
nice completely forgot I hadn't gone
public with it I've told everybody
it's been a bit of an anecdote for me a
bit of a late night drunken anecdote for
me that I'd had a breakdown and spent
time in a minute but it's only since
doing that and I've really looked at it
and really understood it that
moment of oversharing has led to all of
this has led to my first book it's going
to lead to my second book it's led to
this
Reckoning
which would not have happened had I not
have sent that tweet
2019 you um produced the documentary hmm
everybody talks about that documentary
really incredibly powerful but just
artistically brilliant in so many ways
but so many people talk about it you
know I even had members of my team put
in big brackets it is so good when they
were referring to a documentary they
don't usually do that it was really
profound and important in so many ways
how did that change your life
again because
um
and it's this is really hard but I'd I'd
seen that documentary
almost a thousand times because I
watched it every day a year before it
went out
the night it went out
I was absolutely terrified and I as soon
as I saw adverts for it I panicked
and I was you need to call the BBC and
said I don't want to go I I just take it
off take it off I was really scared and
and that that was really unusual with me
because I'd seen it and I I was happy
with it
but going public with it was a whole
nother thing and I was really scared
really anxious and the hot I think the
whole house picked up on it because my
kids went to bed early
my wife went to bed early
you know and she watches you know she
went and she was like she was afterwards
she said she was wearing the you know
the kids might get ribbed at school or
you know your dad's there is that
and I didn't even thought about that
I suddenly thought [ __ ]
you know
I'm letting people in here
and I was really scared
and I remember I that night I had a
therapy session online with my therapist
and when we finished it it was kind of
dark and I thought
well it's got half an hour left to go
I'm not even going to watch it I'm just
gonna go to bed
and I was just about to go to sleep
and see every single device in my house
was beat
everything was just buzzing and it was I
lost God and then the house house phone
went and I jumped out of bed to I didn't
want to wake the house and it was my mom
and first thing she said was brilliant
and that really calmed me down I went on
my watch when she said I've just watched
it she said it's brilliant well done son
huge side relief
and then started looking at all these
messages and emails and they were all
really emotional and like
and moving
and um
went to bed and
got up enrollment to take my dog for a
walk like I normally and I could not
walk 10 feet
without complete strangers
coming up to me in tears I swear to God
going I just want to say Mr Hayward
thank you and I'm normally when you're
an actor people leave you alone
you know what it's like when you're on
the telephone that's that God for telly
but suddenly it was Mr Harewood not the
guy from the Homeland or the guy from
Supergirl or the guy from it was Mr
Harewood excuse me I just want to say
thank you so much tears strolling down
their face my dad had a breakdown and we
never talked about it and just want to
say the fact that you we all suddenly
started talking about it and start
talking about Dad and
I'm blubbing there crying then I go
thank you very much walk up somebody
else excuse me Mr hair we just want to
say and I I suddenly realized how common
it is
and how everybody was touched by it
because you just don't talk about it
it's a shame
attached to to particularly psychosis
and particularly to being taken away
it's a shame attached to it for some
reason maybe because I'm an actor I have
no shame so me
a recognizable
successful actor
talking about it
allowed them to talk about it got a call
from mine saying
phone's ringing off the hook people are
talking about psychosis because they
didn't they didn't that now they
understand what happened to their son
now they understand what's happening to
their who's only just been sectioned
that morning and on this book tour I've
constantly
do signings
and um
nearly every single time I sign I go to
one of these book tours
there's somebody who comes up to buy the
book for it to get signed and they're
crying and they go I've just come out of
a mental institution I just want to say
seeing you
it gives me hope
that I can get better
or there's a mother who says my son's
just been crying her eyes out
my son's just been sectioned he was away
at drama he was away at school because
it happens normally when kids go to
university
or when they go away from home and they
might smoke they might drink they might
find themselves in a strange environment
that's when it happens
and uh
the amount of times I've had to kind of
get up and just hug the stranger and
just say they'll get better
I sometimes sit here with people and
there's a moment where they let the wall
down and the wall can be a number of
things sometimes it's sexuality
sometimes it's something that they've
been holding inside of them you know
they might have told friends but letting
the world in and then feeling that
feedback that that you know people did
weren't attacking them they didn't lose
their job and and that sometimes can be
quite a liberating thing from then on
once we've let the wall down whatever it
is and really let people in and see our
our deepest insecurities or our fears
life can feel different we can be more
open and honest and vulnerable and can't
say that happened because I then had
three years of dealing with it yes tell
me about that because I thought
oh okay I've let the world in and as you
say Where's that moment of
relief yeah and it was torture
because I couldn't cope
with all these people coming up and
saying thank you so much normally you've
got that shield and said you've got that
Shield as a recognizable face where
people don't bother you on the train
people don't bother you in the street
but they were and they were coming with
these really emotional stories
some people some people's parents died
being restrained now I I talk about
seven policemen jumping on me and giving
me what's called an emergency
tranquilization I'll talk about that in
my book
how I survive that I don't know because
countless people have died like that
black people
being restrained by police the amount of
Crim the criminalization of that
the criminalization particularly black
people in that period of illness of
psychosis is look at the people in
America you people shot
because they're acting strange they're
in they're in a moment of medical crisis
but they happen to be naked running down
the street screaming
you will get shot people don't
understand it people have been arrested
people have been one guy knew he was
having one guy I met knew he was having
a breakdown I went to the hospital
they refused to treat him went to
another hospital they refused to treat
him started banging on the door they
called the police he got arrested he got
into he got sent to prison and he was
only in prison that he got treated
so this whole book is has really opened
up the whole
how particularly people of color are
criminalized at a moment of crisis
by being arrested and then being treated
like for me it was only when I showed
the book to my consultant she said do
you realize you were given three times
the legal doses of tranquilizers
and I said why is that she said well it
was it's and then I again once the book
got out I had somebody
contact me saying this is standard
practice
because most people are afraid of big
black men
so most times a large black man is
sectioned you will get knocked the [ __ ]
out
for no medical reason other than we're
scared of this big guy let's just up the
dose here
and that's all it was
so it just all this stuff was coming out
all these stuff was coming at me
and I couldn't really
process it
and I remember going into my therapist
and just flying my eyes out because it's
too much it's too much I can't cope with
it
and funnily enough my medical records
that I find in the documentary
I hadn't opened those
notes for two years since I got them
since filming it
but before I wrote the book and I knew
where they were they were in my flat in
Vancouver and exactly where they were
and
once I decided to write the book
I remember flying back to shoots the
next season of Supergirl
and we flew into quarantine because it
was a couple years ago so you had 14
days on your own and the first thing I
did walk in the flat got my medical
records out and I read them cover to
cover
and that was really tough because you're
reading your Disturbed self everything
that I'd said done was was recorded
so I'm reading all the stuff I did and
flashes of moments that I thought [ __ ]
that's where that memory comes from
second Pace in the middle of the office
and
just the most weird stuff that I did and
said
is it scary to know that it's you're
capable of going getting to that place
yes no and and
you know again I think of myself
thinking about the acting side of it you
know I've always had this ability to
not method
but I really throw myself into a
character and I love that
and I think maybe there's part of me
that
having pushed myself having let myself
go not many people
go there
I literally went crazy
crossed the line into unacceptable
Behavior where your behavior is deemed
we have to
take you away
unsafe for yourself and for others
sectioned
I've crossed that line
so for me now I think
in acting anything up to that line is
fair game it's a fair game and I love it
and I that's why I would more will push
push myself and I look for characters
who are like that because who do push
uh
that's what I don't know that's what
makes acting so so great for me and so
exciting because I can behave like
something somebody else but even reading
about
even reading about psychosis is someone
that's never been through it
it makes me realize that it's completely
possible for me to find myself in that
situation absolutely anybody and that
and that's what because you know when I
grow up with mental health I thought
something happened to other people and
then you and then you get a flavor of it
right yourself and you go [ __ ] we can
all we all have uh mental health and and
reading the stories of psychosis and how
a very normal young man can quite
quickly apparently quickly very quickly
yeah but I mean you from what you've
described it's a series of events over
time but apparently very quickly fall
into that situation
in some respects makes me
realize that you know we are very highly
strong individually I'm in the brain
yeah you know how incredible that is an
incredible muscle
an incredible one so there's thousands
of of of
uh firing Electro at five thousands
every day just going off in our brains
some of the misfire
and you
some of them
very quickly can lead to you taking your
own life
and
you know I know how
having you know having been there I said
I was
I'm just lucky that I think my doctor
said it that he said you know we're
lucky David is uh
calm
essentially
a clown because my psychosis played out
in all sorts of silly ways
but that I did everything that voice
told me to do that night
had that voice of told me to jump off
Thames Bridge I would have done it
I would have done it
so
I've met people who the voice told them
to throw themselves in front of as that
young girl in the documentaries throw
yourself in front of the next white van
and she did
and he hit her
you know it is it is a very powerful
thing
and it can happen to anybody
where did you find yourself today so
you're three or three or four years on
now from that documentary coming out and
you've been on that Journey as you
describe it of rebuilding the house and
yeah I think you know it's taken me this
long to I think I've come through I
think I was really in pain
I didn't realize at the time but I think
I was really specific when the
documentary went out
I was very very vulnerable
and it really was painful I and I it was
uncomfortable
and I used I get what I would get very
emotional
I'd be in Tesco's and somebody had come
up to me as I bought my sausages to say
I saw your documentary and I would just
go
they'd go I'd go why
being reminded of it was they would make
me cry because they'd tell me about
their uncle
and they'd start going I don't know it's
something about the helplessness of
seeing a loved one
acting very out of character
and
some of them don't recover
because you don't understand it so I I
used to find it very emotional
and I think I've moved through that
period of
vulnerability into a period of healing
and I think I'm in that healing period
now I said to you if you just if we'd
have done this doc this podcast last
year I don't think I'd have got through
it like this it would have and every now
and again I find a rising emotional
level as I'm talking about it now
because I know it sounds very weird
yeah I feel like everyone must be
sitting there thinking God he's nuts so
you know
but I sort of dealt with that was there
ever any regrets about doing that
documentary yes really yes
which all disappeared the morning after
I it went out the the regrets were all
the night before after all the regrets
were and then maybe afterwards there was
like maybe I've said too much you know
maybe people don't now see because since
then I've done a lot more a lot more
documentaries
and um more documentaries than I have
dramas and
I've been back in England now for a year
and in America I was playing leading
characters
three-dimensional authoritative
characters and I haven't had a single
offer of anything like that since coming
back
and that's been really worrying I
suddenly thought thing well maybe I
would say too much
or maybe I'm not
you know
you know I thought maybe I may be across
the line
but I don't care anymore and I've sort
of sort of gone well I'm embracing who I
am now
okay sorry you you've since you came
back from America yeah you haven't had
enough uh to play leading characters not
one and do you have a suspicion that
that's to do with I I worried that
that's what I'm saying you say you know
you you talk about do I think there was
a fear of that I don't think that's the
case yeah but it's just but but again
those are insecutors and fears and maybe
I've said too much maybe people feel now
or you don't want One reviewer said oh
David all we see him now is in
documentaries I said but the only reason
you see me in that is because I'm not
going to play some [ __ ] role hmm
I want complexity I want a challenge so
when I'm finding that in the world of
documentaries and I really enjoy doing
that
this has never been done before
ever
keeping a diary has fundamentally
changed my life it's the single thing
that has advanced my personal
development more than anything else that
I've done I always say there's no
personal development without
self-awareness you can read as many
books as you like but if you can't read
yourself you'll never learn a thing this
is the world's first Diary that listens
to you understands you and then provides
you with tailored support from the
world's leading experts in health
Finance work and relationships so that
you can overcome the things that are
limiting you in order to reach your
Highest Potential a limited number of
these Diaries are going to go on sale in
November and the waiting list is open
now so go to
thediary.com and add your name if you
want to come on this journey with me
your career as an actor
um and now as an entrepreneur and many
other things in a director unbelievably
um successful unbelievably successful
um against many many odds
why you
yeah you have the talent you're a Class
Clown you said that you know back in the
school days and all these things you're
a funny guy but that's not enough
I know lots of funny people they're not
actors
I don't think that's for me to say no
but this is this is why it's such a
tough question because I actually think
only you would read you know people
might have told you along the years but
I really think that when you look at
your peers that's one way I've tried to
figure myself out is what makes me
different from these other my peers in
my industry and I go oh ah that's the
thing I'm particularly good at that bit
there that's interesting though because
you know
and again maybe I'm over sharing but you
know my therapist we talk
you know sometimes you know when I first
started to ask him about this not living
up to this ideal blackness
he said well part of the reason why you
have been so successful
is because
you are this
you can go
it can be over here you can be over
there you're formless and then I love
that Bruce Lee will say it's not be like
water
you pull water into cup it's a cup you
pour water into a bottle it's a bottle
you pull water into a teacup it's a
teacup I haven't tried to be one thing
and I think some actors come out think
I'm going to be like this
and I'm going to be like that and I
haven't
I changed my voice because I didn't want
to play brummies All My Life
so I learned the RP
I can do if I wanted to do Street I can
do Street well which is always used to
pissed me up when I was young because
people got always a bit too rather it's
a Carrick I play characters but because
you're I don't know maybe black actors
don't play characters they just play
black people
play characters and I think that
that USP that I've had that I like
playing characters
has enabled me to
change
and it's also what's constrained me
because as I said to you when I came out
of drama school you would you weren't an
actor you were a black actor
these days you're allowed to be an actor
John boyega is an actor
Daniel kaluya is an actor he's not a
black actor when I came out I was a
black actor and I found it so
constricting I'm more than this I can
play anything
and that's maybe you know that's what I
think is my
of my generation that's probably one of
the things that I
perhaps gave me my unique
USP
it's funny the things that often give us
our USPS are also entirely linked to the
things that give us our difficulties and
our struggles and it seems to be the
case in what you've said it's funny
because what I heard from all of that is
that your versity your versatility as an
actor came from the versatility that you
you've had to demonstrate in your real
life as well
100 and I think
that my experience particularly
getting out you know getting out of a
mental institution acting my way out of
my institution uh
it's all been good training and I think
you know my Crossing that line has given
me that USB that kid that came out of
radar if you could have a chat with him
if he was sat here
you could just say a couple of sentences
to him the sentence is I would 100 tell
him
and I tell this to all young actors
two young people be prepared for
the tough times
people think it's going to be life is
going to be roses and people think it's
going to be easy
and yeah things are great now
but
be prepared for when things get a bit
Rocky
because they will get Rocky tough time
you know yourself in business it's not
all about
winning sometimes you learn your best
lessons in failures
so I would would just
and again we'll talk about this with my
therapist that
I didn't take care of my younger self
I did I didn't take care of him so now I
try and take care of my younger self and
I always try and tell people look after
yourself
really look after yourself because
what does that mean to you
look after yourself
uh
control what I can control
and don't if I don't get a job I don't
get a job I can't there's nothing I can
do about that
I can control how I feel about it
and just think it wasn't for me
and right now as I said to you
there's thousands of things that are
going my way and thousands of calls
again acting maybe not but that's okay
it'll come around maybe it'll come
around
I can't control that I can control what
I can control so I've just got to keep
myself sharp look after myself don't
allow I could easily allow myself to get
down now because I've not been
working
but I'm I'm busier than I've ever been
outside of that creating this company
looking to recreate other work doing
documentaries meeting people
it's it's a very exciting time for me
and I wouldn't have had this time had I
been starring in some show
so
there's benefits to having time on your
hands when you said that about
controlling what you can control it made
me realize that this word popped into my
head I almost imagined myself stood at a
Crossroads and one path was like control
what I can control and that says left
acceptance
and on the other hand the right turning
is the resentment that you said your
father had which is that slowly slowly
slow Insidious build up of like
resentment towards the world it's a
choice it can't go that way and I'm
determined not to go that way is keep it
open Keep
attracting Good Vibes
and at the moment that's where it's
leading and it's very it's a very
exciting time I've only been back a year
as well so
who knows what's going to happen we have
a closing tradition on this podcast
where the previous guest asks a question
for the next guest before I ask you the
question I actually was really intrigued
because I know you've just you've
started a production company what was
the thinking behind that and how's that
going
it's a new challenge it's very exciting
and uh you know I think over the last
couple of years I've seen how some
people
I've been involved in projects and I
don't I haven't exactly been run very
well and I think well
I I you know I've now got the experience
to know I can do that job
I I know I'm bringing my A-game but it's
the people above me aren't bringing
their a game
it's gonna make it tough so
I'd like to bring Excellence to
everything that I do that's what I think
I do is I bring Excellence to everything
I do so
I want to put some Excellence out there
and what do you want to make what kind
of things documentaries dramas give
myself some good roles
um why not you know but ask questions of
of the audience work in a different way
create work that isn't being written yet
why wait for somebody else to write it
create it yourself yeah
I'm 27 years old
you look about 35. thank you and you say
to yourself well why isn't that role
come along yet
create it yourself
and that's one thing the younger
generation are doing brilliantly
starting their production companies
you know valuing themselves and I think
that's um
something I really want to do
but myself at the top be the boss man
like you
it comes with its costs but that's a
conversation for another time
um the question that was left for you
what is a personal Legacy
you want to leave
for yourself slash children
foreign
I would say
crack open the universe you know inspire
those around me an inspirational
figure
in in what you do be an example in what
you do
and
let me I'll give you an example of that
but
I've just been casting this film
and as a director
and um two leading roles two black two
two black people
all these young black kids
came in the door young black actors
and the first thing they said oh my God
man I used to watch you when I was at
school thank you so much for I had no
I'm like I was feeling I'd probably be
feeling really depressed that morning
but even without me knowing just being
there
just by doing what I did I inspired that
kid
to think about even becoming an actor
just even think about it
so
I would say to you know that inspire
people by your action
crack up in the universe because we're
still living in an age where we're the
first
I was the first black actor my fellow
this was the first black person that was
still living in that age
so I think there's a whole
Legacy to leave a whole Legacy to open
up
be an example
not just your generation but to Future
Generations
well David I have to say you're
certainly that you're certainly an
example you're certainly that
inspiration and that role models to so
many people so if that is your objective
then I think you've already achieved it
in a tremendous way
um no doubt you've got so much more to
do and I have a sneaking suspicion based
on your tenacity and your
um which has been present since you were
a very young man that you'll find a way
to to crack open the universe in any way
that you desire I have absolutely no
doubt about that in fact thank you I
hope to do that that's my plan thank you
for inspiring me as well and I don't act
but watching um a black man rise so high
and Achieve so much is is incredibly
inspiring for me and my role models um
are varied across Industries and you're
certainly one of them so but you know
what I I'm right back at you because you
inspired you likewise in yourself
inspire people and
you know I was listening to say listen
to your Chris Camara piece which was
beautiful by the way no thank you and
and and hearing how he's inspired people
in a lot of the people who go through
that if they don't think it they can't
even imagine the world but you even just
by being yourself you inspire people so
let's right back at you
well thank you there it means it means a
ton coming from you and I'm sure this
conversation we're going to continue off
there in various forms so thank you
thank you huge inspiration
foreign
[Music]
[Music]